hi Kate hi you like questions you
prepare I know I know
do you get scared in horror movies
totally scared but I'm totally addicted
to them yeah me too I get freaked out if
I have nightmares I know it was a good
movie I want to be traumatized when I go
see a movie that's good cuz you're brave
but then you like you're know that
you're scared but then you like pray for
the same guy do you watch scary movies
if I could jump scared I'll make like
this little shriek but like you won't be
them that's your brothers I was like
scream everybody who came with me
they're just like like we all just like
jumped hey what what which was your
inspiration for this role well I'd read
the book when I when I was probably your
age and then which in the book is
slightly different to this which so I
felt like I was creating something new
like a witch who wears all purple whose
magic comes out of her umbrella and
whose magic is kind of broken I felt
like I was entering new territory
[Music]
there's like fantasy horror which is
like this and so it's like kind of scary
and then kind of like fantasy and then
this horror movie where you pause it and
you're just like yes that's where the
character is like so which one are you
towards this type of thing well when I
was your age the movies that I saw the
theaters that were the most exciting
movies were these films by this company
hamblett and that was Steven Spielberg's
company and these are movies like ET and
laters The Lost Ark and gremlins was one
there's film called poltergeist called
time be careful that one there's a weird
movie that's really fun and crazy called
Time Bandits that I really loved I have
never heard of it such a good movie and
they were these wild crazy fun movies
and a lot of my favorite directors like
the director who made Lord of the Rings
Peter Jackson he started in horror
movies and then went into fantasy and
Sam Raimi who made spider-man he started
in harm
it's a fantasy so I always wanted to
have a career like that and I read the
script and I just always wanted to do
something this stylish and visual and
really just something weird and fun
what are you towards this type of job
well I wanted I grew up on horror so
I've always loved being scared but I
have four kids and I often I go and see
kids films and I think okay nap time
you know because either either they're
really they're really teaching the kids
a lesson or or they're made for the
adults and the kids don't get the jokes
whereas I read this and I thought this
is a chance for me to show my children
the films that I loved growing up and my
16 year olds seen it my 14 year old seen
it my 10 year olds seen my
three-year-old hasn't seen it probably
not yeah yeah yeah I mean I know what
you think but yeah so that's I felt like
it was kind of a homecoming for me yeah
like I'm not I'm kind of scared for a
movies I think I would be okay if I was
like anyone because then I would know
what would happen cuz I see it coming
cuz then I wouldn't be like oh my god if
I'm watching it but I know like if I'm
in that scene then I know that's coming
when we do the otamatone scene when we
got carried off by the automatons I was
when I walked into that room I was
totally freaked out all those doll faces
it was really scary yeah that was weird
so did you want to change a couple of
scenes from the book or did you want to
keep them like I'll try and keep using
well that's a good question
and when you take a book and you
translate into a movie you really have
to adapt it and there are certain things
that work great on the page and certain
things that are just gonna work better
on screen and Eric Kripke our writer who
created the show supernatural did if
it's his favorite book and he adapted it
and there were I just have my own ideas
so what I read I go okay there's
pumpkins but what if they attack and
what if a pumpkin vomits all over Jack
Black's face and okay there's a giant
topiary Gryphon what if it poops dead
leaves and then what if the chair and
the Gryphon are fighting and you just
start thinking of crazier and crazier
ideas so you take the story and the
script and the book as a base but if you
have an idea that works better for the
movie I'm there to make the best movie
it worked very well so um if you're
doing the action
and there's like nothing there what is
it like because you're going like yeah
it's a little bit like what you just did
yes I mean I watched my kids I had this
experience with with my with my 16 year
old when he was about eight and he came
in one day after school and he sat down
you know I mean what's wrong sweetheart
he said I'm so bored I finished fighting
all my imaginary heroes you know and so
it's it's it's literally like that so
sometimes in this movie which was really
great is that we had a lot of the
physical things that the armchair was
there the armor was there the window
kept changing so sometimes you didn't
have to pretend at all because it was
actually all there but there was one
scene where Kate was fighting the
pumpkins and she was holding two green
strings and I said can was wings I know
every director tells you this but watch
out for the pumpkin vomit and then smash
it with your head and then it's have
been Eli I said Eli you've got to talk
me through it and she's like yeah this
is me just acting finding pumpkin here
we go and she went for it I'm straight
well you did very well look is super
duper real so yeah I know I was lucky um
so what Dee what do you do love about
this project you can read a good script
and you can read a great book but it it
completely depends on who you working
with so when I knew Li was gonna direct
it and Jack was gonna be in it I was
there because it's who you play with
that makes the thing fun for me I loved
it because I loved working with Kate and
Jack and Owen but what I love most about
it is the message of embracing your way
yes and that I think everybody tries to
put on a tone down all the things that
make them weird so other people like
them it's something I certainly did as a
kid and the message of the film that
once you kind of own your weirdness and
accept your rudeness that's when you're
stronger
[Music]
lucky shot
how do you feel about scary movies well
I'm scared about scary movies I don't go
to see a lot of scary movies for that
reason but I do like sometimes to be
surprised in a scary movie like being
startled exactly yeah I cannot hear I
can't see it and hear it at the same
time that just is like ah I do the same
thing so I like I just close my eyes and
then I'll look to the side and see what
someone's doing it that's kind of fun
too because you see someone's face the
world or the popgun goes like this I
like that
alright um your character goes back in
time so if you could go back in time
what would you redo wow if I could go
back in time I would go back to the time
of the Pharaohs and I would hide
something in one of the pyramids that
people would find later from the future
and then they think about aliens and
they think maybe that aliens made the
pyramids because of something that they
found in there like you could leave like
a box of like popcorn or something it's
like popcorn the aliens brought popcorn
and they built the pyramids so what do
you enjoy most about this movie I mean
it's a it's a really good movie but what
do you think is the best part about this
movie the best part in India is the
character Isaac is 'red he's like the
greatest evil warlock ever lived I loved
watching the work between Jack and Kate
and Owen and house they created this
little family and how they related to
each other and I thought that was so
sweet and charming yes
um okay so you play like almost like a
zombie so you're some people say my
acting is sort of like that sometimes
but they everywhere so your face looks
totally different so how long did it
take to do that
four hundred years to create that look
we I was in the chair for about four
hours of prosthetics they kind of
streamlined it as we were going to about
three hours but they pulled on full
latex pieces on me all the way through
they attached a little hair on me they
spray-painted me afterwards it was it
was pretty cool I've never done that was
the makeup uncomfortable because all my
friends were just like me but what's the
makeup uncomfortable it wasn't too bad I
kind of got used to it you do feel a
little claustrophobic at the very
beginning but I try to be like you know
I try to just sort of relax and let it
sort of mold to my face it wasn't too
bad it looked very real very well that's
very good
I'm glad you approved so what was it
like working with all these famous
actors like Cate Blanchett Jack Black
all these people what was it like it was
really cool as you can imagine
Jack I knew a little bit a big fan of
Jack I love Jack he's so much fun and
Kate I'd never met before but I've
always been a huge admirer of all her
work so that was really thrilling it was
really nice to meet her and to find out
that she was really a nice person and
really down-to-earth and really easy to
talk to he's pretty cool so when you um
so like there's a lot of surprises in
the movie like like there's startles and
then there's like oh she did not just do
that right okay
how did you feel about the different
surprises oh I like them I like the
different surprises our life the
unexpected like when things don't go the
way you think it's gonna go and I like
the magic I'd like to magic in it I like
sort of the way Jack Black brought his
magic up and the way Owens character
brought his magic up what did you like
just about your character in general you
know I liked the fact that he had like
this fun side of him so that he looked
like this really evil scary creepy old
dude but you could see that he didn't
really think of himself like that he
thought of himself that he was like kind
of cool and suave and handsome and and
like still attractive and
without the objects they're like you're
like death and there's nothing there I
know you're trying to make this thing
open most of my stuff was there most of
my stuff was there and I like being rude
to err most of the time I had a couple
times where I had to sort of imagine I
was were conjuring something or making
something up but you just use your
imagination can you explain about wake
about the clock and why it's animals
right and why it's in the walls so the
camp my character has created built
actually this clock that exists within
the walls of this house that needs to be
set in motion by a magic key and it's in
the process of trying to create that key
that my character dies and disappears
until he's resurrected and he comes back
and he wants to finish his work with
that key once he has that key he can set
this clock in motion and the clock
resonates with the sound of this
doomsday device and the clock is hidden
somewhere inside the house which Jack
Black is trying to find would you never
would you know which he does altima
tweak what you seen was hard to stick
there
I had a scene where I'm supposed to be
blown back you know and when this
explosion happens and they have to light
my shoes on fire so they had to put this
stuff on the bottom of my shoes and then
they torch it up and they said the
flames go up like this on the bottom of
my shoes that was not CGI that was for
real
I had a genuine hot foot it wasn't too
bad actually I didn't feel anything was
okay okay that's that's good [ __ ] like I
know like if they make your shoes on
fire and they would milk you might be
the youngest journalist that I've ever
met what do you thought some horror
movies I've been a fan of horror movies
since I was a little kid I like to be
scared
um but I don't like to be too scared
like I don't like to have nightmares but
I like like the thrill of like a monster
or a creepy character those are fun to
watch because it's kind of like going on
a roller coaster and scary but it's also
fun I love movies but I don't want to be
traumatized
okay like movies like this there's so
much fun because you go in and you're
scared but you walk out laughing just
like a roller coaster what do you feel
that's like being like startled like
this difference between like being on
creeped out and then like startled
jump-scare yeah dude jump scares are
just embarrassing for me because I'm
such a scaredy cat
when I get jumpscared I do make a
shrieking sound and I do jump up and
everyone around me in the movie theater
knows that I'm a scaredy cat
that's a little embarrassing but after
it's over I have like a fun like
goose-bumpy thrill to it to so for me if
you're gonna scare me you can scare me
pretty easily but you won't scare me
that well but if it's like well thought
out you got a creepy mask on I'm
terrified sometimes I feel like I can
feel a jump-scare coming and I'll be
like it's the sound more than what you
see but this is kind of embarrassing too
if you if you have to do this in an
audience then once again the people
around you will be like why is he
plugging his ears such a scaredy cat I'm
like so it's okay for me at a young age
it's like everybody's like yeah okay
yeah he's young I think my scream at
being jumpscared might be scarier than
the scare itself you know jump scared by
that guy's jump scare yeah all yes we
let's all three do a jump scare at the
same time one two
for me it was the first time that I had
magic powers and that was cool I was
able to do this and create a ball of
energy I'm passing it to you now all
right here
I'll just juggle them and I'll stop and
I'll eat 101 okay is it yummy it's
delicious okay that's good do you want
it sure oh my god it's really hot and I
have a magic trick to show you people
all right whoa whoa it's very it's very
scary your thumb yes the doctor doctor
in the house it's amazing how there's no
blood though what personality traits do
you share with your character I do
improv and I met Lois doesn't write your
you had more of a challenge you're not
shy like Lois you've had a more of a
challenge to inhabit your character I
used to be yeah well there it is I like
my character yes I am like Jonathan
Barneveld not that I know magic or
warlock or you at all or play saxophone
I am a musician so I even though I don't
play saxophone I do play guitar so both
of us have a love for music and for like
doing stuff that's odd and strange and
outside the normal what war luck was
your inspiration for this role I don't
think that I was really thinking of
other warlocks that have war locked in
the past I was just creating my own it
was it was my own inspiration just from
my imagination never before I watched
this movie I've never heard of a warlock
so I'm just wondering if you knew
anybody that you just like you tried to
like work off of there's not a lot of
warlocks in movies or TV yeah it's
mostly witches you know it's usually and
a lot of people don't even know that
there are our male witches and there are
they're called warlocks
oh yeah what's the difference between a
warlock and a wizard good question
I'm gonna ask Questlove he probably
knows the answer what was it like doing
all these actions like like the fighting
the dolls that came alive and all that
stuff without the special effects you're
just like taking this back you're just
like I've got a fun story about that one
when I was with I was when you were
working on the key to go into the door
yeah Keaton are behind you with the
Griffin but there was no Griffin there
so when the Griffin was coming at us we
didn't know when it stops screaming and
then we couldn't hear them say cut oh
man yeah there was a lot of that in this
movie because there are so many cool
special effects we had to be imagining
stuff that was there all the time
my favorite was probably the pumpkins
when we were fighting war all three of
us back to back to back I think I burned
a lot of calories it felt like really
good exercise fighting invisible
pumpkins times were cool that was fun
well I don't want a good boo any spoiler
alerts but the ending was cool let's
just leave it at that don't say any
details
Bing was good what do you think was the
most like hardest develop the one where
Lois was saying sorry about everything
that was really intense emotionally it's
always hardest when you have to cry
because you have to like think of like a
sad thing I agree with you high-five
[Music]
[Music]